die forscher der johns hopkins
university veröffentlichten in dieser
woche eine analyse in der sie die folgen
der korona pandemie für mütter und
kinder unter fünf jahren beleuchteten
untersucht wurden dafür länder und zwar
118 stück mit niedrigen und mittleren
einkommen im schwerwiegendsten szenario
könnte es zu 1,2 millionen zusätzlichen
todesfällen bei kindern kommen
so rechnen die wissenschaftler jetzt ist
die frage stimmen diese zahlen wo kommen
die her wie werden sie zusammengesetzt
bettina kochheim also diese zahlen die
duh und auf einer berechnung der johns
hopkins universität die haben sich das
angeguckt und die haben sich speziell
auch nochmal kinder angeguckt weil sie
eben darauf hinweisen wollten und gucken
wollten wir schauen uns ja immer an
kollateralschäden durch krone bei den
schwächsten und wir haben bis jetzt
immer auf die älteren und eben zb
pflegebedürftige geschaut und die haben
sich jetzt mal ganz speziell die
auswirkung für kinder angeschaut und in
diesem fall ist das dann so die haben
ein rechenmodell gemacht und haben sich
118 länder dieser welt angeguckt die er
mit einem niedrigen oder mittleren
einkommen sind also genau genommen hat
eigentlich die ärmsten länder dieser
welt und haben sich angeschaut die
universität
was passiert in ländern die er schon ein
schwaches gesundheitssystem haben wenn
dieses gesundheitssystem durch corona
noch mehr geschwächt wird und die haben
sich das speziell eben angeguckt zum
beispiel geburtskliniken was passiert da
wenn dort zb eben durch ko ohne engpässe
oder weil kliniken geschlossen sind
nicht mehr genug antibiotika da sind was
passiert wenn beispielsweise nicht mehr
genug hygiene herrscht bei geburten und
haben ihm dann geschaut was passiert in
solchen fällen auch in kinderkliniken
kinderkrebsstation alles mögliche eben
mit den schwächsten welche gefahr oder
welche kollateralschäden können dann
entstehen und wie stark kann es kinder
treffen und in diesem fall haben sie
sich dann auch eben mütter angeschaut
wenn es um geboten geht